[Music]
this past summer I landed the internship
of a lifetime no it wasn't that amazing
business development internship at
Airbnb or that super sexy product
management role at Amazon or even that
really cool secret project at unnamed
startup in stealth mode it was an
internship at Costco
yes Costco Wholesale the place that you
might remember as a concrete jungle
littered with oversized red shopping
carts or maybe the place that gives away
free food samples and is featured in
fresh off the boat or maybe you just
remember it as this and you might be
thinking to yourself why would a former
McKinsey consultant former VC investor
and current student at a Business School
in the heart of Silicon Valley want to
move to Issaquah Washington to work for
a large an old-school company like
Costco well as it turns out most of us
in this room have been chasing the next
sexy startup the next big unicorn but
what about the companies that have
endured and existed for years on end I
like to think of these as the Rhinos of
the business world they're definitely
not sexy they certainly have more
wrinkles they're slower moving they're
more methodical but they also have
thicker skin greater strength and more
wisdom and they may just be a little bit
more real than their mythological
counterparts indeed my summer opened my
eyes to just how wonderful these whiners
can be the lessons I learned in humility
in entrepreneurship and an impact are
ones that I will never forget muscle
number one working for a rhino is
humbling my alarm clock blares at 3:15
in the morning I rolled over I hit the
snooze button and I thought to myself oh
I could definitely use at least a couple
more hours of sleep
how could I possibly be this tired when
it was only my second day on the job I
made it out of bed clocked into the
warehouse right at 4:00 in the morning
grabbed a pallet jack and reported for
duty over the course of that morning my
hands got sore from moving what seemed
like endless amounts of campbell soup
from one pallet to the next my back
started to ache as I swept the floors
making sure that our aisles were
Showtime ready for our opening at 10:00
in the morning it was the hardest work I
had ever done and yet it only paid $20
an hour I often thought to myself what
am I doing here I couldn't help but
compare myself to my peers who I imagine
sitting at a desk building fancy models
in Excel or creating beautiful
PowerPoint presentations filled with
interesting strategies and yet here I
was I had a hard time seeing the value
of sweeping floors bringing customers up
at the cash registers and if making food
in the deli but then I met Joe Joe had
been with the company for the last 12
years you couldn't miss him with his six
foot two stature his baggy sweatpants
and the cap backwards Raiders cap on at
all times you always knew that he was on
shift because you could hear his hip-hop
and rap music blasting from his radio at
4:30 in the morning and as I got to know
him I learned that Joe didn't really
know what he wanted to do with his life
but he loved his job at Costco he told
me the company's been really good to me
it rewards me for something I'm actually
pretty good at so maybe one day I'll
apply to be a supervisor and I'll earn
my red vest and then maybe eventually I
could be a manager Joe's story was just
one of the many I heard the summer that
reminded me that my fellow warehouse
workers were each trying to achieve
their own version of the American Dream
they might not have gone to the same
schools as us or works for the same
companies as us but they too hit an
ambition to create a life of meaning for
themselves whether it was Nikki's love
of her 4:00 a.m. shift that enabled her
to pick up her daughter after school
or Alex's drive and determination to
work his way through college they were
all incredibly hard-working dedicated
and damn good at their jobs now that's
pretty humbling lesson number two you
can be entrepreneurial at a rhino I
remember I was out of breath because I
had been sprinting across a hundred and
fifty thousand square feet of concrete
warehouse floor a customer had asked me
if we still had the sleep science
mattress in stock in pursuit of her
question I first ran over to the
supervisor to ask her if she knew and
then I ran over to the stalker who
typically worked the furniture
department and then finally I ran back
to the office to check our a s400 system
only to come up with a lousy answer I'm
so sorry ma'am our system shows that we
have one but we don't know where it is I
thought to myself there must be a better
way to get this kind of information and
so I embarked on a journey to build them
a mobile app that would let them see
real-time inventory levels right on
their phones now let's not get carried
away Here I am by no means a coder but
I'm pretty good at using Google and so I
hacked together what we might generously
call a Minimum Viable Product when I
showed Tyler the merchandising manager
of the app he was stoked he asked if we
could augment it add more data to it
show more dashboards and pretty soon I
had a bunch of team members come up to
me to ask me how to download it and if
they could use it so I identified a
customer pain point I designed a
customer centric solution
I built an MVP and I pivoted on that
product and no I wasn't working for a
unicorn who says you have to work at one
to be an entrepreneur anyways lesson
number three rhinos shape communities
you've probably never heard of a town
called Fremont Nebraska but it's about
an hour outside of Omaha we were there
visiting Costco's construction site for
their poultry processing plant that had
just broken ground Fremont is pretty
desolate has one main
with a couple of stoplights that hang on
a wire a few mom-and-pop shops one bar
in town for all the locals the only
restaurant I recognized was at Buffalo
Wild Wings over the course of a three
night trip we ate there twice and I
remember sitting in the trailer on the
construction site and I was talking to
Jonathan the plant manager and he he was
explaining to me the org chart and I was
shocked at the team size they were
proposing as of April 2019 this plan
would create 800 new jobs in Fremont
alone I was stunned
I knew the Rhinos had impact whether it
was Costco's title as the largest
organic retailer in the US or the
largest seller of USDA choice in prime
beef I knew they were big but what I
hadn't fully realized is just how much
they impact local communities they
create employment they create
opportunity they create an economy a few
weeks ago a CEO verrano came to the GSB
and asked us don't you want to do
something more than just sell ad space
now maybe that's exactly what you want
to do or it's been your life's passion
to start a company to be a management
consultant to join a big tech firm I'm
not suggesting you shouldn't but what I
am suggesting is that you take a moment
to consider what you might be able to
achieve at a Rhino they're not for the
faint of heart they don't offer
free-flowing food or nap pods Starwood
points or shuttle buses but they do
offer a platform for humility for
Entrepreneurship and for impact so while
you're dreaming of what it might be like
to work at the next big unicorn that is
yet to exist don't forget about their
long-lost cousins the Rhinos I'm excited
to announce that I will be rejoining
Costco for their very official MBA
rotational program starting next fall
and of one don't get me wrong it
terrifies me that I'm not joining a
rocket ship or the big three or
fund-to-funds I'm scared that I'm
zagging when everyone else around us
seen
to be zigging but i know that for me
joining a rhino is my best possible
opportunity to change lives change
organizations and change the world
[Applause]
[Music]